[Music]
bagpipes welcomed ukraine fans to hamden
park for their world cup qualifying
knockout against scotland
the winners would go one game away from
qualifying for qatar 2022
first and second generation ukrainians
travelled from all over the world to see
their team's first competitive game
since the russian invasion
i think that it will be even an
emotional game for ukrainian fans and
all ukrainian fans in ukraine as well
the community really
coming together showing the support
wearing the flag it's quite a nice and
comforting feeling ukraine gets
represented by its national team at this
time
it's probably the most important thing
in the world
for us at the end there is a game of
football and obviously scotland do want
to win but it does feel slightly bigger
than that
postponed from its original date in
march the match began with applause for
the ukrainian anthem from the scottish
crowd
kickoff sympathy was forgotten but
ukraine didn't need it
they created the early chances and with
half an hour gone they got their
reward andre yarmolenko getting them a
step closer to qatar for so much tonight
straight after half time the world cup
got closer still
just there with the header
[Applause]
with a simple header 2 nil ukraine
look what it means to him
the scots thought they had got back in
it but john mcginn incredibly headed
wide
wide
with just over 10 minutes to go a
goalkeeping error lets scotland make it
2-1
colin mcgregor's shot just going over
the line just creeps over the line i'll
imagine yes
but with the final kick of the match
artem dovbruck raced through to seal a
3-1 victory
and give ukrainians a rare moment of joy
in a tragic few months
[Applause]
i have no emotions to be honest with you
all of my emotions are left on the
football pitch this victory was not for
me it wasn't for the team members it was
for our country so it was a huge win for
ukraine
ukraine's players and fans have waited a
long time for this fixture but they've
harnessed the emotions of what's
happening to their country to bring
their world cup dream tantalizingly
close
paul reese al jazeera glasgow